[Musique]
on commence par du paris-nice la
deuxième étape était organisée
aujourd'hui pour la première fois à
rochefort en yvelines commune de 900
habitants des 170 coureurs encore
présents sont partis sous la pluie pour
un périple de 195 km pour rejoindre la
commune d'amilly près de montargis on
écoute les réactions des spectateurs
juste avant le départ mais je suis très
content qu'il y à cette manifestation à
rochefort ça fait de l'animation 1
c'est assez calme comme petit village
habituellement à bas tous ces nouveaux
d'entraînement nous ici donc vous pensez
bien
on est chez nous en plus on a eu une
magnifique étape hier un parcours
magnifique puis une belle course en plus
soyez comme quoi des fois pour faire des
belles courses suffit pas avoir d'un des
grands boulevards et autres dépit de
route un peu de vallonné un petit peu de
virages du vent et la pluie tout ça y
est l'étape s'est terminée à 16h30 pc et
16h30 et si l'italien sony à colbrelli
ch qui s'est imposé au sprint sur cette
deuxième étape
or le démarque prend lui la troisième
place et reste leader du classement